hey everybody its Jessie if you're new
to the show I lashing my work it's just
my normal work that I do every day the
whole point is to show what a front-end
developer does even the mistakes that I
make hopefully I don't make too many
mistakes but I just like people to see
that you don't have to be perfect to get
a job as a developer especially people
who are just starting out today we're
going to do something that took me a
while to figure out how to do it's
really cool and useful and if you want
to be able to do server-side rendering
and make API calls then this this is one
way to do it it's not the only way but
it's the way that I found that's the
easiest for me before we get started I'm
going to somebody asked on livestream
how long this is going to be about a
half an hour if there's a lot of people
in the chat asking questions sometimes I
go over but I don't think I've ever gone
longer than 45 minutes but the the code
portion of it will be over in about a
half an hour so at 2:30 p.m. Eastern
time I before we get started just want
to give a shout out to my wife it's our
10th anniversary so sometimes she
watches the show so in case she's
watching happy anniversary I went over
this yesterday the the schedule for next
week so I'm not going to go over it in
depth I just wanted to put up here so
you can see it I'm going to be a syntax
con in South Carolina next week the the
end of next week so my schedule is going
to be off and I have a lot of meetings
early in the week so we're going to
livestream Monday Tuesday at 11:30 a.m.
Eastern time I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to do it Wednesday I'll try and
then I'm going to get in touch with the
people who are organizing syntax con and
see if they're cool with me doing some
live streaming
maybe some interviews from syntax gone
so I'll let you know when I hear back
from them and see if I can do that all
right so let's oh thanks Julian said
Congrats what time is there not it's uh
it's 2 p.m. where I'm at all right so
let me let me flip over here and show
you let me show you the page that we're
going to be putting this on and I'm
going to show you the data you can see
the data on the screen right now
ok so I'll pull this page over so this
is a news page there's nothing on it
right now it's going to be a blog style
page it's on the live chat asks NYC I'm
actually I'm in the same time zone as
New York City but I'm in yeah I'm
actually in Ohio I'm I'm on the very
eastern edge of Ohio so I'm pretty close
to Pittsburgh is about a half hour drive
for me to get to Pittsburgh so you may
be more familiar with where Pittsburgh
is than where Steubenville is which is
the city that I'm in right now so it
says hello from Lafayette cool yeah so
usually I do have people give you know
shout out where they're from us on the
last week people just started doing that
I thought it was cool so if you want to
put in the last ring where you're from
and then at the end of the show I'll go
through and just say where everybody was
from so this is the news page like I
said it's just going to be a blog page
so what we want to do is we want to get
data from a wordpress installation
that's on a totally different server and
we want to display that
here using the wordpress api i'm not
going to go over how to set up anything
in wordpress but the api is now it comes
with wordpress course you don't need any
extra plugins or anything it should just
work i don't think hey somebody's from
Charleston South Carolina I'm going to
be in Charleston next week so Jolie on
the live chat I'll be in Charleston I'll
be there Wednesday Thursday and Friday
of next week for the syntax con
conference she should check it out if
you can if you have time so like I said
the word it's actually super easy I
don't even think you have to switch on
the API I think it's just on by default
somebody can correct me if I'm wrong but
when I started working with it well it's
probably been a year maybe maybe a
little more than a probably a year and a
half since I started working with the
WordPress API you did have to install
some plugins but now it's it's easier to
work with so we want to grab that data
but we don't just want to pull it in you
don't want to client side because if we
pull in that data you know on the client
side in the browser it'll be fine
for for a regular person viewing it but
if a search engine wants to check out
your page they're going to see a blank
page if if all your content is coming
from an API search engines are well some
of them I mean Google's Google search
crawler can handle some JavaScript
pretty well but it doesn't stick around
long enough to get an API call back you
it doesn't matter how fast the call is
I've tested it before with um with just
like you know test data that that should
have loaded almost instantaneously and
and you still it's not it doesn't work
with search engines so the only way that
I know of to make this site search
engine
Elly is to actually make the API call on
the server because we're going to run
node on the server right now it's just a
local development environment so it's
just on my local machine I'll do a live
stream
maybe maybe sometime next week if I can
about actually setting up the server but
on the server we're going to make the
call and then we're going to render the
HTML based on that data we get from the
API on the server and what's going to
get sent to the client on that first
load is all the markup so to make this a
little bit easier we are using next Jas
so check out next I I have links to
everything that I'm going to talk about
in the description so if I mention
something you're not familiar with check
out the description for this video and
the links I do have this repo up now
it's it's on github the link is there
the last couple shows I didn't have the
repo up yet but now you can you can
check everything out so we don't really
need to see this until we finish the
code now so I'm going to move this off
just to show you what the data is going
to look like let me zoom in a little bit
here okay this is what WordPress sends
back if I if I hit this URL it sends me
back you know some JSON all we're going
to get today is I want this title and I
want the content I don't really need
anything else we'll see in later videos
I'll start to get really detailed and
and what I'm getting from here and
actually get rid of all the stuff I
don't need just to make it you know just
a little bit faster but for now this is
just what it looks like I have nothing
special the only thing I added special
in terms of parameters on the end I
don't know if you can see that I did add
post per page 100 but I think I only
have four demo post setup so it doesn't
even make sense I'm going to move this
off to the side we won't really need to
see that will only need to bring that
back if something goes wrong alright so
now let's let's check out the code and
we'll go to our page News News jazz if
you're not familiar with how next works
next basically is a way to let you get
started with react very quickly it comes
built in with a lot of cool stuff like
server-side rendering and all your pages
in your site all you have to do is make
a file in this pages folder and then the
routing just works it handles all the
routing for you so this is our news page
all we have here where we're importing
some components just some basic things
our footer our title we have this head
tag is is custom for for next so we
imported here it's next head so this is
not exactly you won't have something
like this in every react site that you
do at least not not in the same way that
next does it the the only different
thing we had from from previous shows is
we've now added this import isomorphic
fetch so he I'm gonna back the live
stream I'm going to ignore the live
stream for a little bit just to get
through some of this section and I'll
check back in later so if you're asking
a question I don't respond right away I
will I will towards the end so if you're
not familiar with fetch fetch is kind of
the newest way to make to make calls you
know to api's basically it's what you
would have done with Ajax if you're
using jQuery or just
as xhr now you can use fetch for and
it's super simple you'll see the code in
a second when I when I type it up the
only thing is it's not supported
everywhere
yet I mean obviously older browsers
pretty much every version of Internet
Explorer I mean that's that's not really
news that later on I'm sure you know
most browsers will have support but for
right now you have to use polyfills for
fetch and in particular if we want to
use fetch with node on the server side
we can't just use fetch
normally because it's it's normally a
browser thing and note is not running
the browser so we use this npm module
isomorphic fetch it actually it comes
packaged with next us that's why we can
just use it like this I didn't have to
install it separately if if you looked
at the package JSON file which it's not
in the list of things so it's nice that
it comes with this there are some newer
NPM modules that do this as well a fetch
works for me I might check out some of
the isomorphic fetch works for me I
might check out some of the new ones
later on if I think it will provide
advantage if you know of any of you know
newer versions of this that you like you
know let me know let me know what's good
about so let's get started I'm just
going to start typing out what we need
so next comes with this get initial
props function that's anything inside
get initial props that's going to run on
the server side so that call is going to
run but then if you switch over to
client-side routing later on it'll also
run that you know when you're doing so
with next you can do
server side first then switch the client
side once things are loaded you can just
stick with server sides so that every
every time you click a link it's a
complete page refresh you know you can
come you do it however you want to do it
you can do a custom routing but right
now we're going to start with and this
is pretty basic this is pretty much how
it is in the next documentation so you
can check that out too if you want to
learn more about it to get initial props
okay just you I think you'll be really
amazed at how simple this is I know I
was because I like I said I tried for a
long time to get server-side routing to
work with react and I just couldn't find
I couldn't find a good tutorial that was
at my level at the time yeah sometimes
you find a tutorial and it's just it's
just too advanced you know but this was
you know this was at my level when I
needed it alright so I'm just going to
make a couple variables here if you're
not familiar with this syntax you've
using constants that aver
this is es6 syntax or es2015 so this is
just I mean a short explanation is when
I make something a cost it's never going
to change I can't I can't change this
this variable later on there's some
other things with with hoisting that
happens is when you use Const or let but
that's kind of beyond what we're talking
about today all right so we we're going
to use a URL and I'm going to just I'm
going to copy and paste in that URL that
I showed you just a minute ago where
we're going to get that data so I like
to you can type the URL straight into
your your fetch function but I like to
keep it a little bit more clean with
some variables
and I usually like to have my parameter
separate it's not going to be really
obvious right now why we need that but
later on we're gonna have like some
really long strings of parameters
they're going to add to this so it's
better to separate them and easier to
read so for now we can just add we just
add posts because the demo WordPress
site that I'm going to pull this data
from it only has post right now later on
will set up WordPress to have lots of
custom post types and we'll pull
different things and now we're going to
get to you know these first two
variables this was just kind of the way
I would organize things now we're
getting to you know depart important for
it that you really need so this this
syntax is part of it the next three
lines are going to be pretty much
straight from next J s straight from
there documentation away
okay so this is it for fetch
I mean think back if you've done
especially if you've worked with xhr or
Ajax think about how many lines it took
you to accomplish an API call this is
all you need now and if I didn't put
them in you know these variables here
you could just put this whole URL right
here it's it's so much simpler so if you
have a nice fetch it use it I may do a
tutorial video later on about how to set
up your site to be able to use fetch and
the browser and support older browsers
and how to set up that polyfill I just
glanced over at the lodge had somebody
asks a good question
why is the head in the metadata inside
that div yeah so this is weird to have a
div here but I needed to have everything
so basically I needed to have the body
tag have these styles on it but I have
no way at least no way that I know of
with this setup to directly put
something on the body tag so instead of
looking it up and trying to figure out
how to do it I thought I'd just try
putting a div here around everything and
see if it works and it did work so I
would guess that there's a better way to
do this but since I have such a short
timeline for getting this site live I'm
just going to stick with this for now
because it works and then hopefully
later on find a better way to do it but
this looks a little weird but it does
actually work all right so let's finish
this off right we're going to get JSON
back all right so we're going to save
that in a variable called data you can
call
whatever you want okay and then all
we're going to do now is just return
we're going to turn that data you know
what this is going to do is this data is
now going to be available as a prop so
we can go down here and yesterday we
explain how to use props so it's
basically going to be the same the same
concept here where now this data is a
prop prop but I'm going to do I'm going
to show you how how I will be using this
I'm usually not going to make an API
call to just pull one piece of data I'm
going to make an API call to pool a
bunch of stuff in this case a bunch of
posts and I want to loop through all
those posts and then render them you
know a big list of them so I'm just
going to type everything here for
simplicity normally you'd want to make
another component and pass it to the
component and we'll see that later on
but for now we don't need all that we
just want to make sure that this works
make sure we get everything on the page
that we need so we'll go this props and
if I am going too fast I'll answer some
questions in a little bit the same
person asked the question about the div
around everything says as long as we all
agree that it's a hack definitely it is
ahead but sometimes that's the way it is
you just you need to get it done and you
need to get it done very quickly so you
have to resort to a heck so let's go
this prop Sandin data right so we name
that data and we could have named it
whatever we wanted but data is a nice
kind of generic term and we want to use
map
so we're going to use Matt a map
function we're going to we're going to
call it a post since we're getting posts
it makes sense you can call this
whatever you want so that each time they
loop through a different piece a
different piece of data that's going to
be a different post in our case we'll
probably name this something different
when we start using custom post types
for each different post type we'll name
it that that helps keep keep things
pretty clear I'm also going to put this
variable here just to keep track of what
number we're on you'll see why I'm going
to use that in a second and all we need
now only now is just to put in some of
the HTML is going to contain this data
so we want to return if you're not
familiar at all with react all we just
did here when we put this this curly
bracket here is and now anything inside
these curly brackets is JavaScript we
can type plain JavaScript in here so
we've kind of started with JavaScript
inside this this return now we're it's
basically HTML with with a few
differences but pretty much straight
HTML and then now we've dropped back
into JavaScript inside of here so if we
want to output HTML again we need to
return it so we're just going to add
another return and we're going to just
start out we're just going to make a div
to hold this data we're going to give it
a class name you can't just put class
you'll get an error if you try to just
put class you need to put class name
there are a few other properties that
you need to do some different things
with source set is one of them you have
to type SRC and in capital S et
if you you're making a forum or
something and you use the for attribute
I think you have to do HTML 4 with a
capital F so I think they have all those
listed on the react website it's a you
know which which properties are for
but if you're getting weird errors it
for me at least a lot of my errors are
resulting from forgetting to put class
name instead of class so let's give us
we'll just make this a row we're using
materialised framework so a lot of these
styles are built into that framework and
then now here's where that that I
variable is going to come in for react
likes to have a key if you're going to
have you know a bunch of divs that all
have kind of the same thing in them that
you're iterating over they like to have
a key so oops
I messed that up I don't want it to be a
string I want it to be a variable so
let's drop down so you see notice now
we're in that return again so if I want
to do JavaScript I do have to put these
brackets again it can get confusing
we're switching back and forth between
you know it looks like HTML and
JavaScript so we're just going to close
that we're going to close that div
inside that div we're just going to make
an h1 there just a normal h1 tag to have
our title remember we just want to get
the title of the post of the content so
we're going to go post C so now that now
we're in here and we've named we've
named this post we can just go straight
into post and inside the post we want to
get the title
all right title and then if you remember
it actually dropped down one more level
so the way WordPress formats the JSON
you can't just say title you have to go
to rendered and that's that's it with
that should output the title now for our
content I'm going to do something a
little bit different and I'll explain
why I'm going to give this a class of
flow text materialized has this flow
text class that resizes the text based
on your screen width
responsive font thing and that will make
the text a little bit more readable for
us but I'm not going to put the data
here I'm actually going to use this and
this is not as scary as it sounds
alright so I'm going to use dangerously
set enter HTML so we're dropping back
down into JavaScript here to do this
okay so this is built into react I can't
spell to it okay so let me explain why
we're doing this I will pool let's pull
this back this this data back in I'm a
flip switch ever really quick let me
make it a little bit bigger so since
we're trying to pull this content
rendered if you notice there is HTML in
here all right there's a P tag in here
and there could be anything right this
is WordPress so somebody could type in
you know a lot of different tags think
if you had like you ELLs you know
unordered lists you know allies you you
know you can see there could be a lot of
HTML if we just put this here like we
did for the title we're gonna see that
Margo and we don't want to see that
markup I'm just checking out the last
year yeah I know this this seems pretty
harsh but if you have control of where
you're getting the data from and you
know what's going to be put in there
because you're the one that's going to
be putting it in there or you know
somebody in your on your team that you
trust
then there's really
nothing wrong with doing this if you're
just pulling in data from some other
source that you have no control over
yeah then maybe you might want you might
want to think about not doing this yes
you might end up pulling in some some
harmful code you don't want to do it but
in this case you know this this
WordPress site is on some of my servers
I'm actually the only person at this
point that even has access to the admin
panel so so it's okay it's not as it's
it's not as crazy as it sounds it just
sounds really harsh to put that in there
all right so but you can see why we need
to do that because we're going to have
HTML tags inside this content so we need
to render those tags as well all right
so I'm going to save this and then I'm
going to show you the page and we're
going to see all right now I'm going to
bring this in and as it I said at the
beginning I want you to see all my
mistakes so you can see we have a
mistake it's saying cannot read property
map of undefined so somehow I've messed
up in the API call so let's check this
out I do want to just refresh this
quickly to see haha here's a tip I've
had this happen to me so many times I'm
not sure what when I just hit save and
it does the hot reload sometimes things
don't work so before you start to
despair do do a refresh sometimes it
will actually work after the refresh and
for whatever reason it just didn't work
I'm sure there's some good reason why
the the hot reload you know doesn't work
for some things but I'm glad that worked
and we try that before I went back in so
if you can see this part that was blank
before
now as our titles I'm using the bacon
ipsum for this test data it has all our
titles and then it has our content Hey
and that's how you pull in data I want
to let's look at cuts you the source oh
this is going to be ugly I don't know if
we'll be able to get to it but basically
if you view the source you know you'll
see all the HTML there area you know you
see all this HTML here normally if you
have a page that's making an API call
and it's on the client side you know you
won't see all the markup in a view
source you'll see it if you inspect it
in dev tools but not a view source so
this just shows this is what search
engines will see they're seeing all your
data okay before I go to the live chat I
just want to ask you guys you notice
this is different from what it was a
couple days ago it used to have an
overlay this kind of white overlay over
the entire image and then the title was
centered vertically and horizontally I
liked how that looked but after meeting
with the people making the site for they
wanted to see the full color of this
image they didn't want this overlay on
it at all I don't really want to put the
title down here and have you know force
the rest of the content even farther
down the page maybe let's see it you
know normal screen is going to be more
like like this for most people so you'd
see it's already kind of messed up the
formatting I do have it zoomed in them
let me take that back down to normal
size okay so my question to you is I
don't like how this I don't like how
this looks obviously do you know some
way
that we can still make this readable and
also keep the image you know for the
most part without an overlay so I'm
thinking maybe of like having this fade
a little bit more we'll see I've thought
about just removing this section
entirely and just having a title and
then trying to work these images in some
other way so let me know in the comments
or you know here in the live chat I
would really appreciate your opinion on
that I've already spent a lot more time
than I wanted to just kind of trying
things out and nothing has nothing has
has looked right to me alright so now if
if you don't want to stick around for me
to go through the questions in the live
chat now is the time to leave it's
already been a half an hour otherwise if
you have a little bit more time I'm
going to go through the live chat I'm
going to read out where everybody's from
and I'm going to answer your questions
if you have any questions that you
didn't get in a live chat you can put
them in the comments if you don't want
to put your question the comments for
everybody to read just direct message me
on Twitter my link to my Twitter account
is in the description all right so I'm
scrolling up to the top now of the live
chat and let's see we have someone from
Guatemala
and people saying congratulations thanks
for saying congratulations if you missed
at the beginning its I said it's my
10-year wedding anniversary today so
thanks for the congratulations guys
somebody from Latvia Cherry Valley
Illinois Columbia Charleston London
England Baghdad Atlanta Tokyo Canada
Brazil it's Belo Horizonte Brazil
[Music]
Cordoba Argentina Albania ok we have a
question what's the difference between
isomorphic fetch and a normal request to
an API so Marius asks ask this question
so a normal request would normally I
don't know about you but I would say all
the API requests that I had done up and
to the point when I started using react
in this way when I just made it on the
client-side so usually I would use Ajax
because most of the sites I worked on
were already loading jQuery for some
other reason so I would just use Ajax
and I would make the request like that I
did start to switch over and use fetch
but all those were on the client-side so
everything would would load you know the
JavaScript would load on the page and
then the call would be made but search
engines couldn't see the data from that
call when we're using isomorphic fetch
isomorphic is a term that's used at
least in in web development to mean that
it's like something that runs on the
client and the server both sometimes
they call Universal so you'll hear that
it's kind of used interchangeably but to
say it's a nice isomorphic fetch just
means that it is it is fed so it's it's
basically a newer version of an ajax
call that can run on the server in this
case it's running
we're running node on the server so it's
a version of fetch that can run on node
and that's necessary as I mentioned
earlier to be able to render all the
content that you want the the search
engines to see on the server and then
send it all out on that first load so
hopefully that that answered your
question if not you know a comment and I
can answer it in more depth later on all
right we have somebody from South Africa
so they're enjoying the stream thanks
I'm glad you're enjoying it Kazakhstan
Fortaleza
Brazil sorry if I'm mispronouncing the
places that you're from I'm trying my
best
India alright somebody from India's has
a shadrin's ad Abhishek from India is
saying that these videos keep me a hell
of a lot motivated and helps keep the
procrastination on hold awesome I'm
really glad to hear that
I'm pretty much I only keep doing these
if I think you guys are getting some
benefit and sorry guys guys and girls
ice I don't mean any offence by using
that so um yeah so let me know if you
guys think if you people think that it's
useful to you you know please let me
know and and that's motivation for me to
keep doing it and try to do a better job
if you have any advice for me on how to
make these better please let me know
okay somebody says so don't use your a
crowd or wandering straight sided
rendering yeah I haven't worked with
react router enough to even be able to
address that because next handles a lot
of the routing we're going to do a
little bit of custom routing and we'll
get into that probably next week but I I
don't know enough about us I can't
really comment on that what places your
desktop background image from what is my
desktop background image right now
I don't know this maybe this is the
default that comes with Mac so I'm using
a Mac os10 Sierra as the operating
system so I guess that's the default I
don't know let me know if anybody else
is using that I think that's the default
and I'm assuming it's that they're
talking about the Sierra Nevada mountain
ranges here in the US I don't really
know usually the last couple of
operating systems for Mac have been
named after mountains and then the
default image is that mountain okay we
had some stuff answered some of this
okay somebody said we can move the head
into header dodgiest component
that's what I thought so I actually
tried to move the stuff in the header
let me bring that over so we know we're
talking about so so we had somebody in a
live chat mentioned that we can move all
this this heads stuff into a component I
tried to so I try to do I moved all this
to a component and then I just loaded
that component here and it didn't work
basically the the page actually did load
I didn't get you know the pink error
screen but all this stuff that I was
trying to bring in the style sheets in
the fonts not even unloaded neither did
the title didn't load
none of this loaded so I don't know what
the problem is I would definitely like
to just put this all on a component the
one reason why I don't mind it being
here is that I can customize this
although I certainly could have that as
a prop in the component and pass that in
so one thing I could try that I didn't
think about until now is you know what
if I just copied all of this including
this this head component into a
component and then I imported this next
head into that component I don't know
that might work I'm gonna have to try
that so thanks for for mentioning that
because it kind of made me rethink what
I did and realize maybe there is a way
to make it work so I'll maybe I'll try
that after the live stream today okay
okay
mob in 92 says I see that the site
includes the style sheets fonts and
scripts do we have to do that for every
page again and again isn't there some
kind of templating mechanism oh yeah I
mean that's basically kind of like the
last comment yeah I think there should
be a better way to do this I was reading
through the next jst
to see if there was something like that
I think I remember reading at some point
about some layout component and I'm
assuming that it can do something like
that I just need to read more into it
from the last time I use next J us on a
project they've had a lot of updates and
a lot of new features so I need to go
back in and kind of relearn it you know
that what are the best ways to use it
now so at the time when I first used it
I didn't find a better way to do this
for right now since I don't have that
many pages it's faster for me to just do
this but if I had a larger site I would
definitely try to figure out some way to
just put this in a component have a you
know templating like you said but for
now you know once again because of this
very short time frame that the site
needs to launch I'm probably not going
to have time to find the answer to this
and it really mess with it I I kind of
wish I had more time to really do this
you know the best way that I can
ksi defect and reactive okay we have
from side effects and react app I use
Redux saga or Redux Thung I've heard
about Redux I haven't worked with Redux
yet but I've heard a lot of good things
about it watch some videos on it so yeah
definitely I i'm from the little I know
about it I can recommend it as being
something really useful to use with
react okay almost to the bottom of the
latch at um I'm seeing the comments now
when I use that dangerously set enter
HTML someone says they they hate
WordPress but need WordPress I have I
have a somewhat similar feeling about
WordPress I like how easy it is for
people who don't know code to edit
things in WordPress and that's why I use
it in this case that that is kind of why
I'm using it
because we're going to have some some
graduate students who are going to don't
know anything about code are going to
need to input some data but I don't
really like working with the PHP in the
the templating system within WordPress
and I'm not I'm not really interested in
leveling up my PHP skills at this point
I'd rather work on my JavaScript skills
so that's why I'm using WordPress like
this if there were some kind of less
heavy content management system that I
could pull data from that was as stable
and as user-friendly as WordPress I
would definitely try that out as I
scroll down now it seems like the same
reason they said they use it for clients
and that's X that that's it it's really
easy for clients to manage someone asks
Anthony Lopez asks why is coding so fun
I think coding is fun because you're
building something you're building
something that usually helps people in
some way you can build things that are
are beautiful when you build you get
immediate feedback which is really
awesome and if you mess it up that
usually it doesn't cost you anything you
just you know you just undo whatever you
did you go back to the last commit so
that's really cool
other you know I enjoy building things
in in the real world too but you know if
you're if you mess something up when
you're building things in the real world
world then you usually can't reuse it
and you have to go buy more materials
I think it's awesome that you can just
try things out when you're building a
website or an app and not have to worry
about messing it up you know you just
make another branch for your code you
know with get try out whatever crazy
thing you want to do if it works awesome
if it doesn't work well you just go back
to you know your original branch and you
know leave it for later on try to figure
out later I think you know that's that's
cool for me and I really like learn
and learning all the the latest stuff so
I don't know maybe it's not like that
for everybody but at least for me that's
you know that's what I can think of you
just in a minute or two here of why I
like coding so much somebody asks if
it's a pretty common practice so Joey S
is a pretty common practice to just use
WordPress for its back-end API and build
your own front-end I don't think it's
common yet so I first heard about this
probably maybe two years ago or maybe a
year and a half ago and it wasn't really
common they were saying that the
WordPress API at that point wasn't
stable and it could change so you really
shouldn't use it but I found some sites
that were actually using it in
production so I decided to give it a
shot and I built a few sites with it
that are they're actually live and
they're working well and they have been
working you know with with no no
downtime for months I've had no problem
with it so yeah it's not common yet but
I definitely think it could end up being
common that actually I have a project in
mind to make a very easy way for people
who use WordPress to use react as kind
of the front-end without them having to
know that much about react so it would
be limited and that it would you
basically be limited to your your
default pages and posts and WordPress
but they would really just need to plug
in their their URL and then the react
part of it would just kind of take over
and and put out the data so it would be
it would be easier for people they would
have to still know a little bit about a
little bit of JavaScript but it would be
much easier than trying to do it all
yourself so maybe I'll get I'll get to
the point where I have some time to to
make that and maybe maybe you can help
me out with that I'll certainly have
that be open source on github if I do it
okay almost to the bottom I was almost
to the bottom again I think I had some
more some more people typing in and now
the bottom is getting farther away of
this little ahead
alright so okay now thanks for all this
advice on the the text the title text
maybe fade the size um yeah I'm going to
try that so Anthony suggested maybe fade
the sides maybe another black bar under
the image with the white text in it make
it black put a background on only the
text yeah yeah see what you guys are
saying I'll try I'll definitely try
these out change the color drop shadow
yeah I've done that before I really hate
to add a drop shadow since I'm not using
it anywhere else but I'll have to try
these out and see what they look like I
think that that oval fade maybe maybe
that would work too okay so somebody
asks merge a s versus next J s I don't
have enough experience with mine to
comment on that
I like next Jess they seem to add new
features really quickly and be really
responsive on github when you raise an
issue so I don't have a problem with it
there are some things about next that I
wish it could do that it can't right now
or it's possible I I just don't know how
to do it and I'll probably get to some
of those things maybe next week in the
videos a week after but I don't know I
don't really know very much at all about
mine so guess who fill me in in the
comments and let me know what you think
so we have somebody from Romania from
Poland
Orlando Philippines India New Jersey
Saudi Arabia India Russia okay we have
another question here from Josh so Josh
began coding about one week ago
any advice for feeling
overwhelmed at the beginning and not
giving up oh man yeah that feeling of
being overwhelmed will you'll have that
even after you're not a beginner anymore
but it gets better you don't have it as
often and you kind of know how to push
through it don't feel like you have to
learn everything all at once if you
watch a YouTube video or you know read a
blog post on some concept and you're
just totally lost don't worry about it
watch it again watch it two or three
times practice a little bit and then go
come back to it it'll be a great feeling
for you when you come back to a video
that made no sense to you you know a
month or two ago and now you totally
understand it
so I say just keep trying don't don't
try to do things that are way beyond
your level you know take it kind of
slower don't be I'm always going back
and doing tutorials that are like
beginner tutorials and I usually fly
through a lot of the stuff but I always
pick up something useful that I didn't
know so I'd say you know don't don't
have too much pride to you know to go
back to the beginning and kind of try to
relearn some things you always pick up
something new I mean don't spend all
your time in the beginner tutorials but
I'm with you in feeling overwhelmed at
times usually at some point in a project
I hit a point where I just think like
how did I get myself to this point how
am I ever going to get this done on time
and and have it work and you can't give
up you know you still get it you get a
ship the site you know has to go live
you're being paid to do that so you just
work through it just break it up into
small tasks use resources online you
stackoverflow ask questions you know on
youtube videos and if you know somebody
else who codes have them take a look at
your code but I mean I guess that the
best advice I could give you is just
don't
give up and realize that the overwhelm
feeling is normal and you'll get better
and that feeling will slowly start to go
away and not be as bad so hopefully that
helps all right we have somebody from
salvador brazil also you know if anybody
else has any advice for someone just
starting out feeling overwhelmed please
post that in the comments I'm so away
from Seattle Turkey okay so we have some
people with some people commenting back
saying take little steps somebody else
knows the feeling someone said is it
inspired me watching you well thanks I
appreciate that I'm glad it it's
providing some value to you please save
this stream yeah all the streams
somebody just said please save the
stream all the streams pretty much like
five minutes after the stream is over
they go they're available in the free
code camp channel I do have some other
videos on my own channel and that's
linked in the description I'm going to
do some pre-recorded tutorials and put
that on that channel as well but I'm
probably not going to have time until
after this launch the site launches
later this month and then so if you have
any requests for tutorials that will be
kind of shorter more to the point
tutorials let me know if you want to
learn about anything and if I know about
it I'll make a video what can you do if
you have many pages somebody a mom in 92
asks about what can you do if you have
many pages and I think this is referring
back to that you know having all the the
whole content of the head tag in every
page I don't know the answer to that
right now I'm I'm assuming there is an
answer and I just don't know it yet and
I haven't taken the time to try to find
it yet same style is in that menu okay
so we have another recommendation for
the nav menu I'll just I'll skip over
this for now and I'll read them because
that's more advice directly to me and
I'll try out these different things all
right we have another question
Matt Jensen is asking studying web
development of my school but when I
showed them the website free code camp
they said that they coded wrong so I'm
so confused they say you use too much
too much div ICML five uh yeah I don't I
don't know what to say I'm not sure if
you're using something like bootstrap or
like I'm using materialised sometimes
that's the way you have to do it you use
you use a lot of divs
I'm sure there's different philosophies
on how you should structure your HTML I
don't know that I'm in a position to
comment on which one is the best or
which one's right or wrong I mean to me
at the end of the day you got to make a
site that's user friendly to your users
if it's also coated beautifully so that
somebody can look at your code and it's
awesome then that's great too but
especially if you're just starting out
which people are using free code camp
you're usually just starting out I don't
know maybe I don't know if this is good
advice or not but I would say don't
worry as much about your style of coding
don't don't fret about indentation and
how many divs you're using try to learn
the basics try to make some cool stuff
get yourself excited about coding you
know later on when you get a lot better
you know then you can worry about those
tiny details like that but I just to me
I think sometimes people spend way too
much time on those tiny little details
that most people will never even notice
in your code because the majority of
people looking at your site are not
developers so you guys can weigh in in
the comments on that let me know if you
disagree but I would say you know don't
don't worry about that free code camp is
going to give you a lot of good advice
and things and I'm I'm not sure why
they're why they're saying that it's
coding wrong
okay
I think we're at the end now is there
any other another question is there any
other CMS solution you use in your
projects besides WordPress I have used
in the past I've used Joomla and I've
used Drupal I found both of them to be
less user friendly both for developers
and for the clients so I don't use those
unless I really have to like if I'm if I
need to work on an existing site and I
can't and it doesn't make sense to
switch it over
I have tried out some other like kind of
newer really small content management
systems there is some that actually are
built with node that I'm really excited
about but I haven't found one that's
that's at that level that WordPress is
of of just being refined and
user-friendly and stable nothing has as
big of a user base to be able to ask
questions to people so I'd really love
to find something especially it'd be
great if I could find a content
management system that was built with
node I think that would be ideal because
if you're already going to use node
you're using javascript if you're going
to work with react then you can just use
JavaScript to work with your content
management system as well it can be a
lot more lightweight if you don't intend
to actually have templating directly
with that if you're just going to use it
for the API so I'm still kind of waiting
for something to emerge as the
front-runner and that area of I guess
what you would call a headless content
management system where you just got
things through the API and is built with
JavaScript that would be awesome if
anybody knows about something like that
put in the comments please and I'll try
it out when I get a chance okay
somebody's asking about es6 training um
there's a lot of recent
I don't know off the top of my head
where to send you for you know a good
resource for es6 training I know there's
a lot of good videos maybe you know what
if you're still watching
Saurav Kumar's asked for es6 training if
you're still watching make comment in
this video and then I'll see that later
on it maybe I can send you some links to
some of the training stuff that I've
used to learn es6 okay someone says yes
that hope thank you so much oh you're
welcome
but it helped okay somebody said making
your code readable is still important
yes definitely it is definitely
important to make you good readable I
would just and this is entirely my
opinion but and this is this is coming
from someone who primarily works solo on
projects I don't work with other people
a lot right now on my projects so I
really need to have other people look at
my code so I'm in a different position
than a lot of people who are working on
a team where it's more important so you
know take that in consideration with my
advice but I would say the focus for me
is always on what is the user going to
see and making that the best in second
place in terms of priorities is making
my code readable I'm not saying I ignore
that part I do try to make it readable
but if it's coming down to the wire and
I only have I don't have time to do
everything I'll always choose to make
you know the user experience a little
bit better at the expense of readability
of the code and if I have time later
I'll go back in and try to clean that up
but that that's just me okay instead of
WordPress you can use ponzu written and
go okay I haven't heard about ponzu so
maybe I'll check that out thank you
somebody asked if they should learn
jQuery as soon as possible or learn
first learn J as well I think it depends
on what you want to do if you want to go
and learn react don't worry about jQuery
learn j/s is well if you need to make
money right now and let's say you're
doing some freelance work there are a
lot of sites that use jQuery and if you
want to work on those sites to update
them you know then
you'll need to know some jQuery so it
really depends on where you're at it you
know if you get hired somewhere and
their site uses jQuery obviously you
need to learn that so I don't really
know where you're at but if if you don't
need to use jQuery right now then learn
the basics of JavaScript okay but you
never know I mean sometimes I've done a
lot of work that I didn't really want to
do and but you got to do it you got to
pay the bills you got to feed your
family so you learn what you have to
learn to do that so I'm not going to
judge you for promoting with jQuery if
you need to all right this is a good
comment here and we are actually towards
the end so john heiner says you'll
pretty much find out saying everything
and it's opposite one of the
misconceptions I think newbies have is
that there is one way to do things but
there's an ongoing debate about most
things I love that comment so John if
you're still listening thank you that's
that's a wonderful comment it's entirely
right when I was really new I was always
trying to find like what is the best way
and I'd worry like should I be learning
this is this the best thing is this best
way but that's not how it is there's
there's so many ways of getting the same
thing done it's more about your style
and what you like to do or what your
client needs at the time I'm a big
advocate of using the tools the best
tools that you know of for that
particular job so you're not going to
use you know that like I'm not going to
use WordPress and react this combo for
every single site that I do for every
client that's not the answer sometimes
you don't need that so you know don't
don't be so worried about the absolute
right way to do things
you know you'll eventually just keep
going keep learning and eventually you
will find you get better and you'll find
one of the best ways but like John said
there's a debate about what the best way
is usually okay
I see somebody asked if I'm self-taught
this is officially my longest video ever
so if you're still if anybody's still
watching at this point whip 55 years is
that looking at the analytics so thanks
for sticking around for so long uh I'm
gonna have to wrap this up soon because
it's my anniversary and I want to get
out of work here at a decent time but
I'll answer these last couple questions
are you self-taught yes I am self-taught
my degree is in Business Administration
I specialized in economics and Finance I
did take so I say this in high school I
took a course where you learn basic HTML
and CSS and that was a long time that
was maybe I took the course like 2002
2003 somewhere around there in college I
took a C++ programming course I started
a course in web development and then I
dropped it halfway through and now it's
crazy that this is what I do for a
living but that's it that's the only
formal education that I've had I think
there's a value in computer science
degree and I know that there are big
gaps in my understanding of computer
science because I've learned on my own
but in terms of me getting my job done
I know a lot I know what I need to know
to to get my job done and my clients are
satisfied I've I've you know thankfully
I've never had a client that was not
satisfied with their site and let's say
didn't want to pay me or got their site
redone so I've been you know I've been
really lucky in that regard but I have
been self taught so I've if you're
interested in knowing kind of my my
route that I've taken to teach myself
comment below
kind of comment and ask me below and
then I can kind of give you some of the
resources that I've found most helpful I
will say this I don't think I've spent
more than thirty dollars in the last ten
years on resources for learning how to
do web development the best resources
found or free are you some Joe Asif I'm
a freelancer I do some freelance work
now I'm employed full-time at Franciscan
University as a front-end developer I
occasionally do freelance work but it
needs to be a project that I'm really
interested in because it does take time
away from my family I have a wife have
four kids
so I it has to be either what I'm
interested in or let's say they offer to
pay me a lot of money and I just can't
turn it down
otherwise I'd rather spend that time
with my kids I don't know about all of
you but I have a tendency to get kind of
really into what I'm doing and coding
and final watch myself I can spend all
my time doing coding and thinking about
coding and it's easy to ignore your
family which in the grand scheme of
things is more important especially if
my kids are a little I don't want to
miss that
so the freelancing is kind of taking a
back burner now I mean if someone says
to be fair react forward press is
already overkill uh I'm not sure exactly
what you mean by that so I'm not saying
I disagree with that in this case you
can check out some of my earlier videos
where I explain why I'm doing it like
this I think it's it's appropriate in
this case at least I think so but I'm
definitely open to hearing alternatives
to that someone says heck happy birthday
it's it's my wedding anniversary so
thanks for that but it's actually my
10-year wedding anniversary
sometimes it's thanks to the patience
someone again asked what resources I
used please put that in the comments I
don't I want to look up and give you
some links so I'm not going to talk
about it right now put in the comments
I'll give you a better answer
iemon says hello geeks ok we have a
couple more people saying the same thing
what route do you take the teacher so
throw it throw it in the comments and
I'll give you a much better answer I'll
think it out and type it out with some
links for you why did you drop web
development I'll tell you why I dropped
Leadville
I took way too many credits I think I
was taking 23 credit hours that semester
which I don't know how credit hours work
in universities around the world but at
least in the United States a normal
full-time schedule is considered it's 12
credit hours so I was almost double what
they consider full-time so that was a
lot for me also the teacher of that
course had a really heavy accent and I
had a hard time understanding him I'm
usually pretty good at accents but I
said a hard time and what he was
teaching I knew enough about web
development at that point to realize
what he was teaching was several years
out of date and I just I didn't like
that so I needed to drop a class anyway
because it was too overwhelming so that
was on the top of the list someone says
they have dreams with me coding I'm the
same way I'm definitely the same way
that's that's cool
sometimes I actually dream up solutions
that really work it doesn't happen all
the time but it does happen so I think
it's cool all right someone I'm gonna
have to cut this off soon because I'm
getting to the bottom of the live stream
and then more you know I get more
comments so I'm going to say this is the
last last set you know whatever's on the
screen here at the bottom this is the
last set that I'm going to do then I
have to cut it off someone says that our
Support Analyst trying to transition out
of support into development I have a
basket a bachelor's degree Oracle
certified developed an Android app a no
dev experience how do I transition
successfully I would say build some side
projects learn as much you can
build some side projects or get some
paid freelance work if you can you can
also contribute to open source projects
on github and that will build up your
portfolio that's really all you need if
you have a good portfolio that's what
employers want to see the most at least
employers that know what they're doing
when they hire a developer the most
important thing is can this person do
the job and have they proven it by their
previous projects that's what I would
work on if I were you that's what I look
for when when I'm looking at
to hire developers the most important
thing to me is the experience just show
me what you've built my Twitter somebody
asked my Twitter handle it's in the
description of this video okay how to
handle errors in the fetch response
maybe we go over that and a later video
okay so I'm gonna cut that off now
because this video has gone super long
and it's going to be intimidating for
people who are going to want to rewatch
it I'll have to make a note that the
last half hour or so is all kind of
question and answer session but thanks
for all the engagement I think this is
by far like the most active live chat
that I've had in the video and I really
like that I like so many of you have
said you know you're finding this
valuable and I really want your feedback
so I'm pretty new to live streaming I'm
sure I could be doing this you know a
lot better so any advice you can get me
put it in the comments direct message me
on Twitter have a great weekend
everybody I'll be back on Monday at
11:30 a.m. Eastern Time I'll schedule
the the event before I leave today so so
it'll be on the you know view on the
channel and you'll see it but it'll be a
different time than normal so I I had a
great time with you guys today hopefully
this was helpful to you and I'll be back
on Monday